let's talk about cupcakes they are the
newest hottest controversy we always
have a controversy about something that
used to be okay now it is cupcakes a
Seattle school is banning cupcakes in
elementary schools why are they doing it
well we've got some info for you
basically they don't want kids to be fat
that's sort of the short of it so they
are allowing food can only be served at
three classroom celebrations per year
the decision was based on nutritional
factors and economics it's not healthy
for a cupcake party to be thrown for
every student on their birthday because
if you're in a class of 30 that means
you're having 30 cupcakes a year which
is basically one cupcake every 10 days I
don't think it's that bad and not all
families can afford to send treats to
school for a birthday celebration
leading some students to feel slightly
left out so I guess maybe that one has
some validity I think making some kind
of economic arguments or to make sense
but the idea that we're taking away
these companies I know I get it the
sugar we talked about yeah the wings are
all rubbish yeah you're not on think I
mean I get it I get all the stuff when
we talk about high-fructose corn syrup
and I look horrible stuff we're eating
and everyone's getting diabetes and all
this stuff I get all that the reason go
the reason is teachers unions know
better than anyone you don't give rooms
of 30 kids all this kind of everyone I'm
and expect to do your job it's hella
tell ya so that's really what's going on
yet they want to control those kids and
screaming little imps it's horrible it's
disgusting they're all hopped up on
crack no you can says the one father on
the panel well yeah I mean I think it's
interesting that they said in the
article you know be encouraged parents
to bring in other things like erasers
which is hilarious to me I guarantee if
I growing up had had a pair of bring in
something that wasn't edible I would
have found a way to yeah I mean the
entire point of going to school is
having birthday parties nights a week
and in fairness also a lot of kids are
born in summer so it's not 30 now i was
born on labor day and my i'm a virgo
which means i'm a lot of work but i'm
worth it and and the fact is that when
my first day of school and first grade
was my birthday and I told the teacher
it's my birthday and she thought I was
lying I never got a cupcake party it
wasn't until months later she found out
I've been telling the truth and I had a
retroactive one and I I was reparations
that means a lot to me but no it there
are other practical ways you can give
bringing grapes you know like you can do
other things for a party you can sing a
song or do something special to do not
teach kids for 20 minutes right so
you're sort of down with the general
idea this i really be glazed leader
should or did you not me it's not it's
not it's not because of the nutritional
factor they're not afraid that one
cupcake party or even 30 cupcake parties
is gonna cause obesity i'm more worried
about what the kids are eating at home
low-income families can't afford a
healthy meal you know I was in
Mississippi making this film for PBS and
you know in so many communities there's
no grocery stores in rural America and
poor families get all their food from
the dollar store or the gas station
right which is all processed but it's
not that's not yeah that's not the
school's responsibility this is all
about sugar and hopped up little crank
heads okay so if it is about that don't
you still think you lose something by
not having that like if I think back to
my elementary school days those were
great like they'd somebody who come in
with the cupcakes everybody like you
lose something if we don't let kids
celebrate the way kid guess what they
sugar when they're adults too so I get
it you're trying to set some suitors
that have to deal with that right so I
get it but don't you think they're
losing something like you're just losing
something about growing up if you can't
eat freakin cupcakes in school yes
defend the cupcake you boy no kids will
find a way to eat cupcakes anyway I mean
I'm not saying I guess that's a that's a
terrible argument cuz that's kind of
what people who are against gun here
will say but I just feel like cupcakes
are gonna happen regardless maybe have
one party a mom for everyone born in
that month and you have a condensed
cupcake and you can have it at you know
at 3pm instead of having in the middle
of the day i'm justing at solutions here
so we don't stop eating cupcakes right
so you want the cupcakes the teachers
union would say you know what give them
a cupcake as they're leaving school yeah
you know I'm a happy to see one small
tiny victory for a teacher's union
summer in America but I think a very
practical solution is at the end of
every month you have you take one hour
at the end of every month and have your
cupcake party for all the kids who had a
birthday that month that way the poor
kids aren't singled out for more shaming
if they can't bring in cupcakes you just
do for every kid what a birthday in
march we're doing it and we're doing it
in the 30 minutes before we put you on
the bus right that doesn't bode well for
the bus drivers know it though then they
have a very powerful Union to compare to
Dickie the parents a deal with the sugar
high an anomaly right they can just lock
them in the basement and do what they
want with them you guys think we're
gonna ever have like a bounce back
against this health-conscious thing that
we have going on right now because we
are talking about it so much that I do
fear that we're gonna have this weird
thing where suddenly everyone's gonna
want to eat awful what you fear it I
feel like it's the best normal scenario
is that we don't like the food yeah you
think you'd be happy no I obviously
that's that's a problem too but I feel
like we might be a little too stringent
at times I don't know I'm not raising a
child i'm also making my own poor
dietary choices for myself so i don't
know but isn't it isn't it like the done
thing as you just said like it's to me
so you know every time we there's of
shooting somehow the gun sales go up yes
and i think that's partly what's
happening here we keep telling people to
eat well and then everything shows that
they're eating worse is there some weird
what is it with the only way to stop a
bad man with a cupcake is a good name
with that's amazing what an equalizer
type 2 diabetes can be you know and i
think unfortunately it's gonna to you
know if for me as a child it took
sitting next to my grandfather with lung
cancer holding his hand when he died for
me to know i was never gonna eat sir
take cigarettes yeah and i think a lot
of kids are gonna have to see the
suffering of their parents and
grandparents from having an unhealthy
lifestyle to really realize it and even
then they might not because foods a drug
and comfort food is a really nice way of
phrasing something but what it really is
is unhealthy habits and it's not about
changing diet is about changing habits
and that's a lot harder yeah that's why
we talked about this on the show because
we're trying to get a little a little
information across I of course I'm gonna
still eat cupcakes openly and free
you